foreign
[Music]
welcome everyone and thanks for coming
to this session
we realized that we're likely the last
thing standing between you and your
evening activities
so uh we'll jump right in and thanks for
hanging in to the very last presentation
of the day
we're going to talk about mobilizing
document insights with genitive AI
my name is Derek uh Kieran and Jonathan
will be co-presenting today
Kieran and I are product managers at
Google Cloud within the document AI team
and Jonathan is a data science manager
at Deutsche Bank
we'll give an overview of document AI
talk about our genitive AI powered
roadmap
then we'll dive into a couple product
areas document AI workbench Kieran will
go over warehouse and then Jonathan will
share the document automation Journey at
Deutsche Bank
then we'll close with some q a
so let's dive into the overview
document AI helps you tackle the
end-to-end Journey of document
processing
so not only can you read documents you
can help you can understand them from
document AI by classifying document
types extracting fields from documents
providing spatial structure of a
document
summarizing document content
and more and all of this structured data
helps you ultimately make documents
useful
so maybe you want to run analytics of
customer feedback within a form
maybe you're using an application form
as an input to make a decision and a
process or maybe you want to search
metadata within your documents
ultimately document AI can help you
unlock insights and drive automation of
a process that involves a document
so how does that translate into outcomes
for your organization one structured
data can help you drive automation to
improve slas and reduce costs
and with minimal AI experience you can
use document AI to quickly structure
data
and lastly you can manage the document
life cycle including storing organizing
summarizing and searching your Corpus of
documents
so we're delivering business value
across multiple use cases a few of them
include reducing the time it takes to
process expense reports by 90 percent
saving up to 95 percent of processing
time for mortgage applications
and reducing the manual processing time
for public sector applications across
federal state and local agencies
here's a few of uh customers that we're
helping in their document processing
Journey for example we help workday
structure data to automate procurement
and expense workflows
and we help BBVA structure data to
automate processes
to provide the best experience possible
for their banking clients
so in summary the document AI portfolio
helps you digitize structure and manage
data in documents
specifically OCR can help digitize
document text layouts and quality scores
and many data scientists are using OCR
to digitize documents as an input to
call generative models
our pre-trained models help you
structure document data for example form
parser uses the spatial structure of a
document to identify questions and
answers in a form and then return them
as key value pairs
are pre-trained models extract
predefined fields from a document like a
driver's license
and you can actually improve the quality
by adding documents into the training
data set
for your exclusive use
and we'll be diving into workbench and
Warehouse so we won't spend much time
here but ultimately they help you
structure and manage data
so now that we've given this overview
let's talk about how document processing
changes with generative AI we see three
core benefits from generative AI one is
you can classify and extract data from
documents faster
because you no longer need to train a
discrete model per task
second you can unlock new insights from
features like document summarization and
question and answer
and then it generated AI can help
improve the document life cycle
management with features like searching
and summarizing across a corpus of
multiple documents
so we plan to help our customers unlock
this value and that's why today we're
announcing uh generative AI powered
features within document AI
so first generative AI powered search
across a corpus of documents is
available in preview and document AI
Warehouse
generative AI powered extraction and
summarization within document AI is
available in public preview within
workbench
and in the coming months we plan to
offer other features like generative AI
powered document classification and
question and answer
and we offer we also plan to offer
documents as a modality in the
generative AI studio so you can discover
and explore document use cases with
Foundation models
so let's get into the specific specifics
of these products we'll start with
document AI workbench
so for context the current product
workbench is a platform that helps users
train models to extract data from
documents such as a patient's insurance
card
or classify documents to validate form
submissions and decide where to store a
document
or you can split a really long file into
individual classified documents like a
mortgage application and within one file
there's a driver's license pay stub W2
and more
and today I'm public preview for
workbench we're announcing the custom
extractor with generative Ai and the
summarizer
the custom extractor with generative AI
is in public preview and you can use it
to extract data from documents with
freeform text like contracts or you can
use it to extract data from documents
with lots of layout variation think of
invoices W-2s bills of lading utility
bills Etc
or you can extract data from documents
when you have little to no training data
available
so why would you use the custom
extractor with generative AI one there's
really fast time to Value you simply
post a document with Fields you want to
extract to an endpoint and you'll
immediately get structured data in
return
and you'll be able to customize your
results by simply confirming predictions
within the document AI workbench data
set and then that context will be used
to improve your accuracy through Fue
shot prediction
and in the coming months will allow you
to build a data set which can be used to
perform parameter efficient fine-tuning
directly through workbench
and you'll also be able to extract
documents uh that are really long so 200
pages in length for now
I'm going to show you a quick demo but
before I go there let's talk about the
second feature the summarizer so the
summarizer you can use it out of the box
with no training required you can get
summaries for documents up to 250 pages
long you don't need to worry about the
model's underlying context windows or
splitting a document into chunks
and you can customize based on your
preferences for the summaries on their
length and format and coming soon you'll
be able to customize results by
providing example documents and
summaries that meet your needs
so let's switch over to the live demo
and pray that Wi-Fi works
all right perfect
so you come into document ai go to
workbench and you'll simply create a
custom document extractor I'll use one
that I've already created
so you can see you can use this straight
out of the box you can simply call the
endpoint with a document with Fields
defined in the API call and you'll get
structured data in return
or you can go down a path to customize
for your specific needs you can create
Fields what types of data you're dealing
with and how often you expect them in a
document then you can upload a sample
document
to preview results and Define fields
so we'll go ahead and upload this
there's a bit of a lag so I'll show you
one that's already predicted
but you can see one minute into this
process I'm getting extracted values
from this contract so the title the
legal parties the jurisdiction Etc
I can create a new field
and in real time we'll see a prediction
from the generative model that will tell
us how long we have to terminate this
contract at the end of the term which is
30 days
and also within workbench
if we
choose a term or a field that the co
that the generative model isn't able to
recognize we'll see that
and we'll actually be able to teach the
model so this is the health and wellness
industry
and then when we mark this document as
labeled
all of these predictions are saved as
context including the correction that I
just made so that the next prediction is
more accurate
so I come into build
and
I can now create a new version
and creating a version essentially saves
the fields that I just defined and the
documents that I saved as context so
you'll have consistent performance in
production
you can take quality to the next level
or do model evaluations by importing
additional documents and managing the
data set
you can use this Foundation model to
automatically label documents to help
you build those data sets much faster
and then again coming soon you'll be
able to fine-tune this Foundation model
directly here in workbench with the
documents you build in your data set
and of course you can continue to train
custom models which still helps for
documents especially with low to
moderate amounts of variation
so once you've experimented you can come
in and see the versions that you've
created Run evaluations once you have
test sets
and ultimately call an endpoint with a
document to get structured data back
so that's how the extractor Works let's
show you the summarizer so again you'll
come into document ai go into workbench
and go ahead and create a summarizer
and again you can call this out of the
box to get summaries or you can go down
a path of customization and let's just
directly upload a sample document
and we'll be able to customize this
based on our preferences for the summary
of length brief moderate comprehensive
or bulleted and paragraph then we can
rewrite that summary play around with
different
summary formats and then choose the one
that best fits my needs
and then we can come back and see that
those settings have been saved and again
create a version with those settings
that will be used when you call the
foundation model
you can also set those settings when you
call the individual API with a document
and again you can come in and see the
endpoint
call these endpoints with a document and
get summaries in return
so thankfully the Wi-Fi held so let's go
back to the slides
okay and
we'll skip these videos that were my
backup
and we will go
all right so again these features are in
public preview you can go to workbench
right now in the console within document
Ai and try it out a few of our customers
have tried this out and let's hear what
they're saying
will use generator value and workbench
to extract data from new document types
including highly dense and unstructured
documents
and they'll provide a faster more
accurate and more secure service to
their banking clients
automation anywhere helps customers with
end-to-end automation through a
workbench they plan to use generative AI
to help their clients extract and
summarize data for more document types
and get started faster than ever to
drive business growth and automation
Iron Mountain offers an information
management and content Services platform
called Iron Mountain insight and within
this platform they plan to use workbench
to help customers summarize documents
and improve their customer and employee
experience by extracting data from
documents with limited or no training
data
orbai offers an observe learn and
automate AI automation platform which is
powered by document Ai and rbai is going
to use custom extractor with with
generative AI to offer faster time to
Value customize results for higher
accuracies and help more customers Drive
important outcomes such as 70 cost
savings for Contract Processing
contextual AI offers contextual language
models which can be customized based on
their customers knowledge bases and
they're turning to document AI to
extract rich and complex data that other
extraction Solutions have failed to
capture for them
they plan to improve the extraction
accuracy with few shot predictions and
fine-tune it and they will structure
data from documents with a more accurate
and scalable approach that will be an
input for their clms
so a big thank you to our early
customers who've tried this out provided
the feedback
and finally we continue to invest in the
core product workbench a few of my
favorite features are automatic
diversity sampling to improve the
efficacy efficacy of your training and
test sets and integration of our custom
extractor with bigquery so you can
analyze the data across your documents
and support for more advanced tables
so I'm excited to see what you all can
accomplish with workbench and with that
I'll turn it over to my colleague Karen
thanks Derek hi everyone I'm Kiran
belari a product manager for document AI
Warehouse so I'm going to spend the next
uh
10 to 12 minutes talking about warehouse
and then we'll talk about some customer
use cases
so Warehouse is so what is Warehouse
right so some of you may not be familiar
with it it's a new service that we
launched around went into GA around six
months ago it complements the rest of
the dock AI portfolio very well what it
is is it's a fully managed service to
search to store govern and manage the
documents but not just the documents but
also the extracted the classified the
metadata we call them properties
so it includes all the data that goes
with the documents all managed within a
single platform
so this has several advantages over
incumbent repositories that you may have
currently you may be using so the first
is we apply the best of gen AI
Technologies
to solve several problems right one is
to be able to find the right document
through search a better search
experience to answer questions that are
that may be buried in the documents to
summarize documents Etc
and I can go over some demos on this a
little later
secondly we automate a lot of the
document processing by supporting batch
pipelines to process documents through
extraction classification Etc
third we store and manage these
documents at Cloud scale so we've had
customers with hundreds of millions of
documents right so you're not not
talking about thousands of documents
with really we're going to six and seven
figures and eight figures
uh the next is really mitigating risk
right so what does that mean so the
couple of things we do we enforce
governance policies access control and a
document by document level we also uh
support things like retention policies
which are required in several regulated
Industries
and thereby manager help mitigate risk
ensure compliance and then finally it's
integrated with a lot of other Google
cloud services that you're probably
already using dock AI being one of them
but also a bigquery GCS and we're adding
other services as well
so as you can see Docker Warehouse can
be applied to is applied to a very wide
spectrum of Industries spectrum of
functions also different workflows and
applications as you can see so it's a
very broad horizontal platform for
managing documents
uh we've seen a lot of interest from
Industries like Banks insurance
companies engineering companies
supply chain organizations
government
Healthcare and Life Sciences but it's
not just that right it's a pretty broad
platform so you can use it for a variety
of other Industries and functions as
well
uh so if you look at a typical life
cycle of a document through Warehouse
what happens is your document may be
resident in any on-premise or Cloud
repository or
it may be coming in through your
scanners or email systems it gets
dropped into GCS and there are
connectors to do that
once it's in GCS we have a dock AI
pipeline that you can set up to kind of
take it through the dock AI processing
optionally through OCR extraction
classification Etc summarization use a
variety of different processors that you
might want to use and then eventually it
gets indexed into doc Warehouse
so at that point we we index it we also
offer in addition to our own UI we also
offer apis and Trigger notifications so
that you can power your your other
workflows and applications that might be
using these documents
so it goes beyond just our UI and it
kind of helps power your business
workflows as well and then finally it
integrates a big query through a
connector so a lot of the data that gets
extracted and dropped into a warehouse
gets exported directly to bigquery so
you can run SQL views you can run a
variety of other
analytics run your bi dashboards to get
insights on the data that's buried in
these documents that would have been
buried in various repositories or silos
okay so that's high level architecture
we recently launched a tight integration
with Doc Ai and what we mean by that
it's a the slide looks a little more
complicated than it really is they're
really four touch points where we
intersect with dock Ai and uh workbench
and the rest of the docker portfolio so
the first is running the dock AI
pipeline right so we manage a scalable
pipeline to bring in these documents
through extraction classification
summarization Etc that's number one
secondly we uh also are able to take the
post hitl output so what happens is a
lot of customers use dock AI but then
they have their own human in the loop
that's running on workbench
the output of that even the loop that
can also be natively extracted that can
be ingested into warehouse through this
Pipeline and so some of our customers
use that to be able to verify the
accuracy of the uh the review or the
labeling or for audit purposes so that's
the second use case third it can be used
as a data set management platform
because a lot of the production
documents that are coming in it goes
through dock here processing you still
want to be able to cherry pick some of
the search filter cherry pick some of
the documents use that to export it to
workbench for further up training your
models so it's used for that and then
finally the last one is extracting
documents that have not gone through
dock a processes processing right so
that they may be resident and Warehouse
they may be just blobs they might just
have a raw text extraction you want to
apply like specialized processors or be
able to apply some of the general
processors that Derek talked about
so as you can see uh there's several
different touch points with dock AI that
you can use this for
okay so let me jump into what we are
releasing now and what we recently
released so we recently released a gen
AI search feature so this is uh
this this is quite very interesting so
I'll talk through the right side of the
slide which kind of shows a demo so what
you see here is there are thousands of
coveted research documents these are
completely unstructured documents you
can ask a natural language question
those get answered and basically we
basically highlight not just the snippet
of where the answer might be in the top
five documents so the three things it
does first it finds the top five results
that might contain the answer it
highlights a snippet that might contain
it and then third it summarizes the
answer as it would appear in each
document so the answer summary is
probably where a lot of the value also
is because you eventually want to get
the some of these documents especially
research articles or reports can get
pretty dense in terms of finding the
answer
so that's one uh in addition to that we
enforce access control on these
documents so you'll only see the
documents that you have access to which
is pretty important in a lot of use
cases
and then this can also be used for doing
things like answering questions with
simple table lookups we support large
documents as you are all aware there's a
token limit but these documents can far
exceed the raw text can far exceed the
token element because we do support
large documents as well and you can have
like annual reports you can have like
various reports that exceed like 50 100
Pages sometimes
okay so that's generous search that we
Laura launched recently today what we're
announcing is a couple of uh other
features on top of that this one is what
we call Select document queries within
AI search so what what you're doing here
is we also support filtering of
documents so you can actually filter
these documents based on the metadata
that either extracted or you you may
have human tagged by through humans or
it may be pre-tagged sitting in your
other repository right so we support all
kinds of metadata
so you can filter these Down based on
the metadata and then you can basically
select these documents and ask questions
that only cover the selected documents
and there's a few use cases for for it
so for example in this case uh it's a
legal firm that's current or it's maybe
the legal department that's trying to
identify uh various contracts and
understand the differences between the
scope of uh engagement right if your
Consulting contracts so how does a scope
differ between these two contracts or
how does the term differ for example you
can get answers that kind of compare
two documents or aggregate the get a
summarized answer that spans across
these documents they have multiple use
cases or you can even just select a
single document and query that right
that that's also a very valid use case
which many of our customers have asked
for
so that's one uh the other use case is
around summarization so Derek just
talked about announcing the genea
extractors and summarizers we do cover
the both of those in our batch pipeline
so as you're bringing in the documents
you can have them go through and that's
what the animated demo on the left is
trying to show is you're setting up this
pipeline where you select a classifier
you can select extractors for let's say
there are 10 different classifications
of documents you can select 10 different
extractors some of this those could be
more traditional Docker extractors some
could be genei powered extractors and
then you can also have a summarizer that
basically which would extract the
document summary
and that summary is kept in a field
which is kind of highlighted on the
right side the the advantage of the
summarizer is basically now uh and we've
seen this a lot of users and analysts
they had to open a document to figure
out exactly what it's about now the
summary kind of helps them get a quick
sense of what so they can actually sift
through 50 documents on the page and
quickly identify the document they're
really interested in because once you've
got to run into like say millions of
documents you will find a lot of search
results that are valid right so you
still want to be able to narrow down
these documents
so that's all I had to present uh let me
hand it over to Jonathan who's going to
come and talk to you about uh document
AI at Deutsche Bank
scared
hi everyone
um I'm going to give you a brief flavor
of our experience using document AI at
Deutsche Bank
um
Deutsche Bank we receive many millions
of documents every year from our clients
vendors and other partners and the
processing of those documents is largely
done in a manual way
um you know extracting information from
those documents archiving and so on and
this obviously has the downside of
increased costs and some sort of
handling errors that we'd like to avoid
so we're interested in automating those
processes and we feel that document AI
warehouse and workbench are very good
candidate tools for doing that
we've at this stage completed a detailed
evaluation of a workbench and our first
use cases will be going into production
with that um in in the coming month or
so
um meanwhile our
investigations of Doc AI Warehouse are
just just beginning
um beginning with um the extraction side
and uh and workbench and it's worth
pointing out that an important
um Factor when determining what tools to
use for this is the complexity of your
documents so for
um simpler documents
um you know shorter standard format
documents
what we found is that the
um the workbench parsers the ml parsers
for extraction that you get in in dock
AI are highly accurate
um but worth noting that for for
higher complexity documents so either
very long documents documents that have
high variability free form documents or
indeed just documents where you don't
have large samples to train models
um they're in those circumstances the
genoi functionality that Derek spoke
about really comes into play
um at DB
um we've sort of started our dock AI
Journey with documents that are at their
simpler end and this is because that's
really where we have the highest volume
of documents and therefore the highest
costs and so what we've really looked at
so far is creating custom parsers using
workbench rather than any of the the
newer gen III functionality
um
what we have here is just an example
form that we we've built a custom parser
for in this case related to cross-border
payments but we've
um created parsers for many many
different documents in our
investigations and largely we see the
same kind of performance for all of them
and on the right hand side here you see
a plot of the extraction accuracies for
the various different data elements that
we want to get out of this document as a
function of the training sample size and
you see that for already trading sample
sizes of as little as 200 documents you
get very high accuracies
and that's kind of a performance that
we've seen with multiple document types
coming now to Doc AI warehouse at
Deutsche Bank our main requirements here
are related to
um sort of regulatory requirements that
we have
um with retention and automated deletion
of documents and also to do with scale
you know we have the order of a billion
documents and we want to be able to
support 70 000 users
um of particular interest for us though
are some of the uh the summarization and
search functionality that Kieran spoke
about
um we're particularly excited by that at
the moment it's quite difficult for us
to extract information and to gain
Insight from from these vast number of
documents that we have and we feel that
by by moving to Warehouse uh we'll be
able to unlock that potential
um in a similar way to what we've
already done with the workbench we're
we're starting to do experimentation
against Exemplar use cases
um for warehouse and that work is just
really beginning
and of course what we're really
interested in isn't just solving for one
or two use cases and the real value
comes from figuring out how to solve for
one use case and then solving for all of
the use cases that are of the same
pattern
um so we want to scale this up
um now to many many use cases and we
we're going to do that by uh what we've
we've created a shared service
um that has a you know it gives access
to people from across the bank access to
to those doc AI tools and other tools as
well and makes it easy for them to
therefore use those tools
um we currently have about 14 use cases
in our our backlab the first ones will
be going into production shortly and
we're adding to that backlogger all the
time
foreign